le drapeau français et bien affichée en
première page mais ce matin impossible
de parier
les onze opérateurs retenus n'ont pas
encore mis à jour leur site internet
il faut donc attendre quelques heures
pour miser légalement sur les matches de
la coupe du monde ou sur les sports
hippiques
une manne qui jusqu'à présent partait
vers des sites basés à l'étranger
on estime que cette année le marché
total du jeu d'argent en ligne en france
offre à peu près un milliard d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires on pense qu'il va
tripler dans les trois prochaines années
et qui deviendra le deuxième marché en
europe derrière l'angleterre
un marché juteux qui devrait rapporter
plusieurs milliards à l'état sous forme
de taxes à condition que les internautes
à y bien jouer sur ces sites les
gourmands venus pour cela cet organisme
l'autorité de régulation des jeux en
ligne se doter de nouveau imposé
notamment en matière le président du
tribunal de grande instance pourra
ordonner le blocage de l'accès à ces
sites ou le déréférencement de cécile
nous pourrons demander au ministre du
budget le blocage des flux financiers
les sanctions pénales de prison ou une
amende ont été considérablement
renforcés mais déjà la loi fait
polémique car derrière ces sites se
cachent des noms bien connus
françois pinault patrick le lay ou
stéphane courbit très proche de nicolas
sarkozy
on retrouve toujours les mêmes groupes
c'est à dire ce que l'on appelle les
amis du fouquet's et maintenant chacun
sait très bien ce que cela veut dire
ce sont les amis du président de la
république qui seront les mieux servis
qui vont récupérer à la fois la manne
publicitaire quand ils sont des groupes
de médias et qui vont aussi récupérer la
manne des mises d'argent en étant
opérateurs de jeux sur internet
à quelques jours de la coupe du monde de
football on peut parier sur quinze
sports pour le poker il faudra attendre
le 28 juin dies